former NFL player played for the
Patriots and all-around good guy Ivy
Leaguer he's Ross Tucker who joins us on
the program I'll give you the official
introduction the Ross Tucker podcast you
can check out Ross's YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash Ross Tucker NFL let me
start with Cam Newton there Ross good
fit for both Cam and the Patriots well I
think then it's an awesome move by the
Patriots just in the sense that there's
almost no risk and there's a ton of
upside a potential reward I mean all
we're hearing so far is that he's making
up to 7.5 million which leads me to
believe it's actually a lot less than
that so it sure as heck is worth a
chance from the Patriots perspective but
I had Andrew Brandt on my podcast day
he's not even sure Cam Newton ends up
making the team when you look at the
contract yes now I think he's on the
team but I got crushed by people on
social media when I said I don't think
it's a lot that he's the starter I mean
first of all Dan Belichick never looks
at things from just a one year time
horizon and so if you think about if
it's even close between Stidham and cam
he'd rather go with Stidham and have the
young cheap healthy kid for years to
come secondly speaking of health if Cam
were as good as everybody's saying he is
right everybody's got all this
excitement the last couple days I
understand it but if the Carolina
Panthers thought that Cam Newton could
be the Cam Newton of 2015 or the first
half of 2018 they wouldn't have cut him
there I mean they wouldn't have cut him
making 18 million to give Teddy
Bridgewater more than 20 million year or
Ron Rivera if he thought Cam could be
the same guy he would have been pounding
the table hey let's bring him in along
with Haskins to give us another option
he didn't do that so that says a lot to
me how do you think the Patriots will
and should use Cam Newton well I think
that's probably the most intriguing
aspect of this whole thing right is
because
he is sort of the polar opposite of what
they've been doing the last 15 years
it's been primarily dink and dunk from
the pocket cam strength is the deep end
routes the deep digs and running the
football so how early in training camp
Dan do they start to implement those
things when they don't know for sure
it's gonna be cam instead of Stidham or
Brian Hoyer or whatever but that's what
I think you would see from New England I
don't think they brought him in to not
run the ball if he can't run and I had
Booker McFarland say this to me on my
show on Monday if you can't run I just
don't think he's that valuable and it's
a one-year deal I think at this point
whether he can run the way he used to or
not then the pagers gonna run them
because they have to and cams gonna run
because he's not as effective if he
doesn't and that's his best chance to
get a big-time 100 million dollar deal
maybe he can be this year's Tannehill
who knows yeah I'm with you on that I
just don't bring him in it's like
drafting somebody and then saying we
don't want you to play the way you did
in college we want to change you the
beauty of what we saw with Cam when he
went to Carolina is Carolina adapted to
Cam and made it comfortable for him
coming in you know Belichick can design
all kinds of offensive schemes here and
Josh McDaniel the same way I I'm with
you I got to find out what I have with
Jared Stidham unless they've found out
what they have and now they're willing
to bring in Cam and say let's have some
competition maybe Cam Newton's our
future and not Jared Stidham I think
it's all about options and cam gives
them another option extremely
inexpensive I mean why not why not bring
in cam and see what it can do
but you gotta remember this to Dan and I
know you know this and I know it from my
time in New England
Belichick doesn't really care about how
big of a name a guy is when he brings
him in I mean think about all the guys
over the years that went there and were
never heard from again
Albert Haynesworth Torry Holt John Lynch
Reggie Wayne
Joey Galloway Chad Johnson I mean over
the years the patrons always get these
big names Oh Patriots did it again Paige
but then a lot of times look some of
them worked out Cory Dylan Randy Moss
I'm gonna worked out but a lot of them
that's where their careers went to end
that's where their careers died if we're
talking to Ross Tucker if you had a
chance you're a free agent you could
play for the Patriots next year or the
Buccaneers who would you want to play
for without any hesitation that had my
bay buccaneers I mean first of all Dan I
think you know me by now I'm just gonna
go to whatever team gives me the more
money because that's what I'm playing
for my life money's the same money's the
same I'm going to Tampa because I think
that they have a legitimate chance to go
to the Super Bowl and win it you know
I've said this to people before I played
for five teams bunch of different
quarterbacks when our quarterback was
Drew Bledsoe in Buffalo we thought we
were gonna win right when my quarterback
was maybe some of the other guys I had
they'll remain nameless
he kind of hoped you would win when when
my quarterback was Tom Brady in New
England you freaking know you're gonna
win even when you don't you know you're
gonna win and so that immediately
transfers to Tampa Bay I don't care if
they're down by 10 to the Saints in the
third quarter fourth quarter all those
guys in the Bucs
look over they see number 12 we're gonna
win we have Brady and I don't care what
my guys like Devin McCourty and Matt
Slater say they get to the fourth
quarter and we'll see if it's Cameron
but if it's Stidham and then look over
man I hope this kid has at them and I'm
just saying that permeates throughout
the entire locker room huddle
organization everything I think people
were tamp are gonna play better
I think people in New England are gonna
play worse I think Brady's a big factor
in that do you have the list of
quarterbacks that Ross Blount for yeah
I'll name names Tony banks Chad
Hutchinson Drew Bledsoe Tom Brady okay
so the one of those I was a groomsman in
his wedding so I would not point out
that he was one of the ones that
we were hoping he would win let me throw
some air in the bus I'll go Charlie fry
under the bus
Charlie fried it was kind of a we're
hoping right let's be honest and
Cleveland we're hoping you are an Ivy
League guys you like to remind us
there's there's talk a possibility of
maybe spring football for the Ivy League
what do you think of this possibility
well it doesn't surprise me I mean the
one thing I can almost guarantee you Dan
is that whatever the most cautious or
safest option that's what the idly is
gonna do I mean we know they were the
first one to cancel the basketball
tournament you kind of funny looking
back on it how much criticism they got
for that and the whole world canceled
like two days later but if they feel
like there's any threat at all they're
not gonna get these guys in that type of
risk and the thing that's unique about
the Ivy League is they already don't let
them go to the FCS playoffs so the Ivy
League title is already the be-all
end-all so if they played in april/may
you know that's basically what their
season is it's not like oh now we can't
play North Dakota State in the
semi-finals
they can't go there anyway so it
actually works the thing I find
interesting about it is there have been
more and more Ivy League guys in the NFL
Oh recently guys getting drafted never
here I think Princeton had three or four
guys the last couple years what happens
if the NFL drafts in the middle of your
season you know what happens if you get
dressed if I've games in you get drafted
by the Bears in the sixth round and like
you still have five more college games
to play I mean it it's it's a unique
scenario to say the least it's good to
talk to you Ross you got do you think
the NFL season starts on time I do I
think obviously it's all dependent on
the next four weeks the next six weeks
and what happens with baseball and the
NBA right now I do think it starts on
time my concern is whether or not
they're able to finish the season
everybody watching listening please wear
a mask
we need football I need football make it
about
me I everybody I'm gonna make this about
you the dance they have had discussions
here of who has physically the biggest
head who's been on this show since we
started zooming Paulie where do you
think Ross Tucker rinks he's the Michael
Jordan a big not even really that close
okay Fritzi I gotta go with Ross I know
he's zoomed in a little bit and he's
trying to sit back as worth saying this
but big head from McLovin are we talking
like metaphorical like he's got a big
head cognitively oh yeah it's Ross yeah
see yeah I gotta go with Ross Ross do
you have an eight head I do I gotta tell
ya it's a legitimate factor for me in my
career in the media I actually lift my
neck twice a week because I don't want
to look like a bobble head when I'm on
Dan
Patrick's YouTube show right like your
your neck to head ratio in life is very
important so I lift my neck multiple
times a week just so I don't look like a
bobble head when I'm wrong with you your
head doesn't fit on my screen there you
go
there you go now you just look like a
bobble head you couldn't have the Ross
Tucker bobble head because it would tip
over I went to a real eye beauty school
not Dartmouth who won the Ivy League
title this year you call the game it's
because they're able to get people in
he's Ross Tucker former NFL player host
of the Ross Tucker podcast and his
YouTube channel at youtube.com slash
Ross Tucker NFL great see Ross thanks
for joining us with you at any time
that's Ross Tucker friend of the show